great
uh thank you everyone for coming
and uh
thank you uh everyone for coming to the
today seminar it's a great pleasure to
have professor yano kung from mata ai as
our speaker today so uh but first our
baidu
cto dr iphone 1 would like to give the
welcome remark to ya and to the audience
so hyphen is a baidu chief technology
officer while he remains to be an active
researcher in many areas of ai and deep
learning
in particular
natural language processing like machine
translation pre-training language models
knowledge graphs et cetera and
especially technologies first
please welcome hai phong
okay
hello hello everyone welcome back to
it's the second time foreign
nearly 10 years from past and deeply new
as well everyone knows has transformed
every expense of machine learning and
artificial intelligence the industry as
well as
academia now today yes is here again and
we will learn his amazing
thoughts about
ai let me give a brief introduction to
our
today's speaker dr yellow queen
currently he is the chief real scientist
mathematician and the field professor at
nyu
he is also a member of u.s national
academy of science national academy of
engineering among us and other owners
here was recognized as one of the three
deeply new trainers and was honored with
the asian touring award for
conceptual
thank you
thank you thank you hyphen
yeah thank you this is a great
introduction so actually in 2013 i
remember i looking back to the end to
rutgers university i think it's in 2013.
if we can't remember us yeah so yeah
it's such a coincidence so great uh so
this is a general yeah i visited baidu
uh the same year um
uh in the building that we can see right
behind hyphen actually
yes
uh great so uh so this is agenda for
today so before the research talk
so i thank you yeah for agreeing to do
this uh 30-minute session for
conversation with the january croon
so so basically it's informal like a
mega panel so we have a number of
especially invited guests who will
reserve the slots to ask the answer some
questions
and this is just for fun and for
education of course and so hopefully the
audience will enjoy that as well so uh
first uh
let's see so we have a
uh
so
lee dan
and dr lieden and the doctor andrew
nori
and
so
let me
see uh yeah so we will start with uh dr
uh return uh ask questions so so uh uh
first uh let me introduce a little bit
about that dr lydon so uh welcome lee so
lee received the 2015 igp signal
processing society technology
achievement award for the outstanding
contributions to
automatic speech recognition and to deep
learning
and he also received the 2019 igp
industry leadership award
for the leadership in pioneering
research and development a large scale
deep learning
that that disrupted the worldwide speech
recognition industry and for leadership
in natural language processing and
financial engineering
so lee is a fellow of the canadian
academy of engineering he was the chief
scientific ai
officer at the city of america and
before that he was chief scientist of ai
and head of deep learning and technology
center microsoft and currently he's also
advising several ai startups in silicon
valley's and is affiliated professor at
university of washington so lee welcome
to badoo again and please share your
question too young
yeah thank you so much yeah um
so i have
yeah thank you i listened to many of
your talks i enjoyed every single minute
you know when i was interacting with you
uh many years ago
before i joined hedge fund company so
during my microsoft i um
you know i learned so much from you now
after i went to a hedge fund company i
encountered so many different problems
and they don't allow me to say anything
outside but now there is an opportunity
i
i can make an exception to ask you
questions for me to get you know some
insight from you uh about you know some
of the challenges that our industry is
facing is financial engineering uh
challenges so we saw part of the problem
using deep learning and there are still
a few very important problems that we're
used to to solve so the
critical problem
in financial market prediction
really is
to solve the problem of having very
different distributions between training
and tests this is the kind of problem
that you talk about extra interpolation
extrapolation and the one that young uh
that joshua bengio and jeffrey keep
talking about
so it's because the market changes very
fast i mean because of a competition
like everybody knows you know the
distribution really changes so much
and then i recently read a paper you
wrote with your colleagues about
uh in high dimensionality you know deep
learning can do the kind of
extrapolation rather than just thinking
about doing interpolation
and that kind of insight really helped
me to think about how to handle this
kind of very fast you know
non-stationary process where we are
going to make a prediction on the market
this is a very very difficult prediction
in natural language where everything is
static you assume that you know the
distribution is not very different from
each other whereas information must be
changed
and but there is a specific reason why
it changes there is some economic laws
that governs the competition and that
change so my question really to you is
that to what extent do you think the way
that you think about interpolation
extrapolation the generalization
capabilities of deep learning networks
can be applicable
to the problem where the dispersion
changes very fast or very dramatic
and essentially you really don't know
what the next experience is going to be
i learn i would love to learn something
from you
well
you know i'm not an expert in financial
prediction or financial markets at all
never quite parked in the area but one
thing i know about it is that
um
you know it's very noisy it's very noisy
by definition because uh
you know the other
people kind of playing on the market are
basically trying to make it
unpredictable
yeah so exactly
and so the noise level is very high and
the signal level is very low and the the
big question here i think is
not just how do you handle
non-stationary signal but how do you
handle
very high
noise levels
and how do you handle uncertainty in the
prediction
because it's not just a good thing to
just predict but it's also a good thing
to know when your prediction is is good
or bad and uh
and and produce you know perhaps uh
uh some sort of distribution over your
or your prediction right
yeah
and so how do you handle noise and in
fact this is this is a problem that i'm
i'm really
very interested in that i'll i'll talk
about in the technical part of the talk
uh which is how you how do you deal with
uncertainty in prediction
and so if you are
if your goal is to really predict
something and there is a large
uncertainty in the prediction it may
actually be very difficult to do but
if you give up the
ability to
predict the noisy signal you just want
to predict some representation of the
noisy signal um like you know is it
going to go up or down you know in the
long run or you know is it a good thing
to buy or whatever right some other
quantity that is not
a direct prediction of the signal but
some something that's you know simpler
to predict um then it might be then it
might be possible to do a better job so
basically i think
uh perhaps one of the issue that the
machine learning community has had is to
insist that uh models should be
generative essentially or predictive
um
we should give out the idea that
we should predict the variables that we
want to model
and so okay it sounds it sounds crazy
when i say it like this but i'll try to
explain the technical part of uh yeah
yeah thank you very much for this
insight yeah so i just read that's a
question for noise right and then there
is a non-stationarity and there you know
uh yeah of course you know things like
self-supervision you might help but you
know in the context of financial markets
i really don't know
yeah okay okay so the yeah so the lowest
part is really the input
and the output actually is the signal
but the signal actually is very often is
a fixed now when trump have a tweet
things change and after a while it comes
down right those are the kind of things
we talk about uh uh as
uh as the noise but on the other hand
um
there's an advantage of um of the kind
of industry there because we kind of
understood the reason why the noise is
large
and why there's another stationarity and
why is it that you know the description
changes and these three things are
related to each other right
you mentioned the noise no it's actually
you know it doesn't really deal with the
direction but we do know the kind of
direction of our you know aspect right
so the the advantage of the industry is
that we sort of using economic theory we
understood the nature of competition and
how you have to model many you know
multiple asian problems and they are
fighting each other we know they are
doing this and that gives some prior
knowledge and the key really is how to
incorporate that parameters into the
model in such a way that uh you know the
problem can become somewhat easier than
otherwise impossible so so compared to
the kind of video prediction that you
talk quite a bit about you know we
actually try to use the similar kind of
things that you have to solve the
problem it turns out that it's all
disaster you'll never be able to solve
anything but because you know the the
domain
uh information wasn't actually
incorporated at all but you were using
the the type of uh you know many of the
talks that i heard you actually were
using
sort of you know it's not really noise
the way to do video prediction right you
actually assume that there are multiple
uh videos that can be predicted all
right and each of those should be
uh and that's a very very thing just
doing you know the mean square era you
get all the uh you know sort of um very
uh
difficult you know
very noisy uh sort of prediction coming
up you want to predict
the clean trajectory
but there are multiple of those you have
to choose which one
is good to be predicted in the video
it's very it's some of the different
problems but i think the prior knowledge
about the uh about the structure of the
output is something that
ought to be uh incorporated so i'm
looking forward to your uh to your talk
about technical solution to uh to this
solution and that's what would inspire
our industry a little bit so the second
question do you have time to have a
second question i have only two
questions yeah so we have uh we have a
couple of more
more guests so maybe can we kind of uh
okay
yeah i'll save the next question after
other people ask questions thank you
thank you thank you lee uh
yeah
so uh next uh let's welcome professor
sanjeev aurora from princeton university
sanjeev are you there
yeah oh great hi thank you
yeah so let me give you one
ten second introduction so professor
roland with the department of computer
science at princeton university he has
done great research he's really great at
inspiring research in theoretical
computer science and the recent years of
theoretical machine learning so uh
professor aurora is a member of the u.s
national academy of science and thank
you for for coming and please start
sharing your question thank you
uh hi john um yeah i haven't chatted
with you in a while you know and then i
can all uh and for the last 10 years
you've been always alerting me to
the next big trend in your opinion so
what is that today
i mean in machine learning machine
learning uh well it's a combination of
two things um i think it's uh first of
all supervised learning this is not news
of course i've been talking about this
uh for a long time including you know
you and i have been talking about this
for for a while and the reason i'm i'm
so interested in star supervision is uh
because if we want to build intelligent
machines we need to
get them to learn to
figure out how the what works mostly by
observation
and
you know south supervision basically is
kind of uh a way to
approach that problem
um
and uh of course i'll be talking about
this uh uh quite a bit and um
uh
and i think um you know one approach to
this
um again i'm going to repeat what i i
just i just said to tuli
we may have to abandon the whole idea
that we need to predict things
um we want to model the
dependencies between variables
um but um if we want to train the
system for example to
figure out how the world works by
watching videos or by predicting what's
going to happen in the video there is no
way that we can train the system to
predict everything that's going to
happen in the video down to the details
of the texture of the carpet on the
floor and the moving leaves on the tree
and so we have to abandon the idea that
we need to predict basically we have to
give up generating models and and this
is kind of uh
you know sounds kind of
unorthodox what i'm saying here
um but uh i
really come to kind of believe that um
very strongly so the next big thing is
uh
um i would say non-contrasting methods
for non-generative models
okay
define it by negative negativity but
i'll say what i mean by that later oh
okay so i look forward to that
uh andrew you have more questions
i know i see you have many other
questions so i'll before
okay so
great thank you thank you
so uh
so next let's welcome professor andrew
matamari from stanford university
so uh andrew is with the department of
statistics and department mathematics
and school engineering
so uh he has his i to me he's a as a
highly accomplished researcher in many
areas in statistics mathematics
theoretical physics and information
theory and machine learning so professor
mahnari has received numerous honors and
he was invited an invited speaker
intercessional speaker at the 2020
international congress of mathematics so
uh andrew
welcome to baidu and and please hear
your question
okay thank you for the invitation hiyana
so i thought of asking a a kind of uh
non-technical question a sociological
question
so this is a trend that i've witnessed
for at least 15 years
before deep learning but has been kind
of enhanced by deep learning it has been
the convergence of various communities
in the you know computational sciences
applied mathematics etc
if i think of perhaps 20 years ago there
was optimization and information theory
and statistics and
theoretical computer science and these
were you know well
separate groups and
they are progressively
you know
unifying in the sense that
you know people think of the same
problems and often use the same tools
and of course there is a lot of of
promise to that a lot of positive to
that
but okay the way i feel is that there is
also some risks in the sense that
often i see that different people
think different things when they say
i proved this or i demonstrated this or
this is the right question or this is
the right problem
while you know a smaller community has a
very precise notion of what are the good
problems and the good answer to those
problems and then different communities
of course don't have the same idea of
that but unless the within the community
that there is a kind of
very precise notion of what is the
standard of evidence etc
um
yeah so i see this as as potentially
risky you know a trend that has some
risks in it and i wanted you know i have
an idea what is your
your opinion or your your feeling about
that and
you know
what to do about it
okay um well i think
i think it's good that people come to a
field
and contribute to it with very different
sets of methods
and very different way to approach the
problem very different ideas about what
it means to prove something
very different strategy
to come up with sort of
you know new models or new ideas or new
explanations for them
in fact a few years ago sanjiv invited
me to
ias to give a
talk where the title was the
epistemology of deep learning and it was
really about the fact that
um the the you know certainly at the
time uh much of the journey was very
very much empirical
um it was it's very sort of you know
creating an engineering artifact
uh and and and then we need to
understand
uh develop the theory that sort of
explains what why this artifact works
and what the limits are and that's where
that's where we need a very wide
collection of people with different
mindsets and different background
cultures to to help so people coming
from uh you know probability theory uh
you know random matrix theory large
deviation all that stuff right the
community you know well people coming
from
information theory and um and uh you
know applied math and et cetera people
coming from theoretical neuroscience you
know people like like sanji who got
interested in machine learning you know
boss barack from harvard you know
there's a whole bunch of people kind of
you know started to get interested in
this
coming from theoretical computer science
and then physicists um who are you know
coming back to the to the field because
they were interested in neural nets back
in the late 80s early 90s and now
they're coming back to
uh you know working on um
uh you know analyzing kind of trying to
understand what goes on in uh
deep learning system
uh you know you know with techniques
that come from condensed matter uh
physics essentially i think we need all
of this you know i
um i'm fairly sort of uh
open to like different types of
methodology because
um
you know
because i think we we need different
ways to think about
uh problems that are that are that are
complicated
so i don't i don't see an issue with the
fact that people come with different
standards i see this as a good thing
okay thank you
not being a heretion myself you know i
don't
know yeah i i kind of you know part of
me completely agrees with you
part of me is sometimes scared when i
see
a paper is published and people believe
that that paper proved something
and then you read the paper and
it's not the case
and clearly uh you know there are
um there are proofs whose uh
applicability you know is fairly uh
restricted and and and
you
you know you have to to know exactly
what the conditions in which the proof
apply but sometimes you know proofs that
seem completely ironclad can actually
send you in the
in the wrong direction right so there
was a time you know before diploma was
popular
where uh
you know you would talk to the
theoretician about machine learning and
that heritation will tell you you know
it's very easy you can approximate any
function you want
by you know taking your input uh
expanding it on a very large dimensional
uh
set of basis function using a non-linear
function and then everything becomes
linear in that space so now i i just
need to do you know uh convex
optimization
and and then you had to you know talk to
them and convince them that
uh
to make a complex function uh tractable
or practical
you know you have to
you have to let it have several steps
you know sequential steps meaning layers
in a
in a neural net or it could be steps in
the program or whatever right
and that the theory basically cannot you
know could not
you know
make that visible and so
um so there was a very kind of difficult
dialogue with with theoreticians at the
time it's changed since then at least
with some of them not all of them
i should say
uh but uh
um you know sometimes uh things that are
approved um turn out to be misleading
even though they're right i completely
agree
thank you uh
actually
yes that he's not a direction this
reminds me
i think in 2010 right i invited again to
cornell to give a talk and during the
dinner in the thai restaurant
i always remember the restaurant
so uh so jan told us the story when
young was young and he derived
some
beautiful theorems which he thought that
was very creative as it's a hard
deliveration but until later he found
out it's actually called the martinko
pasteur law in random agencies
uh
yeah so so uh so that's uh like making
me like enough evidence that uh
yeah is actually theoretically uh well
prepared and
yeah
i had some help with this i was working
with a physicist who
did all the replica symmetry breaking
calculation which i couldn't possibly do
okay
yeah yeah it was a good story and uh
so um so alex are you here
yeah i don't say which eric otherwise
eric
okay so uh so let's go to the next uh
question so by
uh i'd like to invite someone from i do
research to give to ask questions so um
share and he he graduated phd from ucla
in the in the computer vision group with
uh zombie and
union and he will and has some questions
for you so ching wen
uh hi professor raku welcome to baidu
yeah i have one of fundamental questions
related to a general ai for you
nowadays we have seen a great success of
deep learning in terms of performance in
all kinds of ai tasks
do you think a grammar-like
representation of for example
anal graph or passing tree
is still missing in the state of the
other ai system and deep learning
methods so that the learned knowledge
lack explainability uh if the answer is
yes how can we achieve it if not uh why
i want to listen to your opinion
thanks
okay i i think i think there are two
questions in your in your question right
one question is uh how can we get
uh machine learning systems or deep
learning system in particular
to
represent complex objects that are
structured so things like like trees and
graphs as opposed to just you know
multi-dimensional arrays right which is
basically what uh
what deep learning system can manipulate
today
um i mean i'm sort of excited by the
whole sort of graph neural net or
geometry deep learning
uh thing
uh i i think you know it's a
kind of
full of potential
maybe not for the kind of ai that we're
talking about but uh you know certainly
for
applications to um to data that do not
come to you in the in the form of uh you
know multi-dimensional arrays but uh in
the form of functions on graph
for example so
um so i find this really exciting um i
think there's a lot to be discovered
there
in order to be explored
um
and then um
and and then there is the the
another question kind of wrapped in in
your question which i failed to remember
um yeah actually it's only a one
question so uh
do you think the grammar-like
representation is missing in the current
deep learning level yeah okay so i i
think what's missing certainly is uh
reasoning
and i'll address that in the talk but um
i think the ability of deep learning
system to reason i think uh
you know would be really
really powerful the the main issue there
is that
traditional types of reasoning that are
based on symbols and logic basically are
incompatible with gradient-based
learning right because they manipulate
discrete objects with sort of discrete
functions and so if you're gonna
you know train a system using
gradient-based learning that's you know
basically not going to work so so that's
the big question how do you replace
symbols by
uh you know vector of activities
basically representing symbols by by a
vector or by you know some some
numerical object and then replacing
numerical
uh replacing logical operations by
numerical ones um essentially but there
was another piece to your question
initially which was about explanation
so i have a rather unorthodox opinion
about explanation which is that i don't
believe that explainable ai is
particularly useful
i i think uh
it's
it's useful for bad reasons it's useful
because it's
uh it's useful for an ai system to
provide explanation because it reassures
uh the the people that that use it
but it's not actually useful
okay okay um
and you know people are kind of uh
hesitant to use a system who's
functioning they don't understand
but in fact we we we work with uh
other humans and we don't understand how
they work
at all
um
we take uh we take drugs uh for various
ailments whose
mechanism of action is not understood
but their efficacy has been proven by uh
you know decades of testing of careful
testing
so i think you know
there are certainly some situations in
which an ai system has to be able to
provide an explanation there's no
question about that
but for most uh applications of ai uh
i i don't think providing a uh
explanation is particularly useful
okay yeah thank you for uh serving yeah
thanks
thank you thank you yeah do you mind
delay your talk about five minutes well
you're you're only committed to it till
8 30 so wait no okay i don't mind okay
so uh i thought i saw cam raised uh
raise your hand so so karen yeah you
were colleagues right att laughs so
that's right
i don't know why my machine is being so
sluggish
anyway um
so i i raised a question in the chat
with uh lee dong you were sort of
suggesting that um
adversarial um
sort of things like you might get in a
stock market or something where the
other traders are all trying are not
randomly trading but they're they're
actually out to get you
um and i'm thinking that you know i i
once heard somebody suggest that we
could build a machine to play chess by
sort of assuming the other players
playing randomly
but in fact i think it's important to
think that the the adversary is is
actually out to get you and so you know
you were sort of suggesting that you
could respond to
some of the things that litong was
talking about like thinking that it's
random noise and i'm thinking it's it's
quite precisely non-random noise you
should be much more paranoid than than
just you know random noise anyway that
was just a comment yeah i agree
i could i'll think about that as a
parallel noise right something like that
but is there any kind of machinery that
you know about
that may address this type of i mean a
gang is one way of doing that right you
know but it's a very primitive people to
think about that doing that so i wonder
whether uh you know you can offer some
structure
and answering them yeah
well um
you know i think uh if you have if you
need to use a water model for an ai
system to predict what's going to happen
you know possibly as a consequence of
its actions
uh if there is uncertainty in the world
that predictor needs to have some latent
variable that accounts for all the stuff
you don't you don't know
um and and so
um
you know the stuff you don't know
includes if you're if you're playing an
ever struggle game it includes what your
adversary is going to play and you can
try to assume that it's going to play
you know the best possible what you
think is the best possible move
against you
um but uh but beyond that uh
you know in situations that are not
particularly adversarial
you you still have to figure out you
know what what is going to happen like
you know you're driving on a highway
and uh
you know there are cars around you and
you know it's a good idea to be able to
predict what's going to what the cars
around you are going to do to kind of
uh drive safely and defensively and
they're not necessarily adversarial
um but the number of different things
they can they can do is very large and
so how do you sort of represent in your
mind you know all the
possible
features that that may that may happen
and sort of
um
uh
you know you can model this by
essentially what amounts to a religion
variable here is everything i don't know
about the world and when i change this
latent variable my prediction varies
over
a set of plausible
uh plausible futures
and if i know the uh the world is
adversarial then
i pick a value for the latent variable
that uh you know maximize maximizes my
cost
i guess
and and the stock i mean certainly the
stock market is like that right except
you you don't have one adversary you
have a whole bunch of them
great
i i'd like to ask again so eric are you
here
otherwise we conclude this session of a
conversation session uh thank you yeah
and this is this is very fun for those
uh who have still have questions so we
we can leave the questions after the
talk and uh
uh i need to tell you and that we don't
really have a
time limit
so i hope it doesn't mind to stay to 8
30
yeah so uh
17 minutes let's use it very cautiously
and so let's make sure the questions are
first for some focus on questions that's
relevant to the talk and also
also i'd like to
see this also opportunity to for friends
to say hi to jan and
i see like uh i see for example ima from
berkeley
and uh and also
htao from harvard or okay str he just
left so yeah if you guys want to say hi
to two yen so this is a good opportunity
i'm better than you guys showed up
okay
yeah i have a question maybe i'll answer
the first question right oh sure yeah
this is a great talk okay um
so the reason why you gave up uh
predicting
images at the
pixel level is because it never worked
well in your experiment or is it
something that's a you don't see the
need or predict the pizza in order to
achieve your goal of learning the world
model for your childhood architecture
it it works in simple cases so if you're
trying to predict uh things like you
know
green cars on a black background or
something like this or you know
uh
you know monsters moving in a video game
or something like this works okay
but if you want to apply it to like
natural videos um no it doesn't work a
lot of people are trying to do video
prediction
and they've been really not doing it
okay but otherwise i thought that that
they would be very very useful in
practice or like in china in china for
example baidu can produce the product
where you get each other you know video
cameras all over the place right sure
you can actually monitor people and if
the criminal want to put out the gun or
knife to do something before they do
that you know police arrive already or
it would be very useful if you can
predict maybe 10 you know maybe 20
seconds or something okay all right
that's good thank you very much actually
actually this is important so by doing
uh i don't believe battles are heavily
involved in this in china
okay good for you
and other other questions
uh like uh questions about ebm question
about reinforcement learning
i saw some reinforcement learning
experts here like chang new from the
university of texas austin so professor
liu do you have any general comments or
questions
uh yeah thanks um i actually
want to ask about the contrasty versus a
regularized method it looks to me that
uh both methods are very similar right
so you can almost view like contrastive
methods as as some kind of approximation
because the regularization is pushing
everything
towards the data and that's like
equivalent to penalize everything every
other data points right so you can
almost think uh congratulating methods
as a
kind of monte carlo approximation to
the regularized methods
and uh and i i also think that there are
two different things that are slightly
different one is the traditional energy
based model where
you uh
uh things like contrasting divergence
uh another is the more recent
self-sufficient even though both have
this contrasting in the name but i think
they are somehow different i can sort of
say that the regularized methods is uh
it has as advantages over the
contrastive methods for the self in the
self-supply setting but do you think the
same holds for the energy for learning
like boltzmann distributions like i
think like uh what what you know
like a contrastive divergence uh did you
see a disadvantage over there as well
yeah so i i think in fact that uh
i think contracting methods are the same
all over so things like contrast
divergence is a contrasting method gans
are constructive method denoising
autoencoders are a contrasting method
siamese networks with positive and
negative pairs are contracting methods
they're all contracting methods in one
way or another if you interpret them in
the context of energy-based models
they're all they're all just different
ways right
yeah yeah yes
because everything fundamentally you
have to do some contractions in order to
land its model okay right but but the
the point i'm making is that uh
when your representation space is high
dimensional
and your energy surface is very flexible
is you know as lots of parameters for
example
you're going to have to push up on a lot
of places for it to take the right shape
um
and it might be you know it basically
[Music]
it requires a
number of contrastive samples that is
exponential in in the dimension
and so
it's doomed i mean there's no way this
is going to scale up absolutely no way
that that's that's related to the
behaviors of the problem uh i agree um
but but in the end you know if you want
to do the same thing in the high
dimensional space you have to somehow
integrate over the high dimensional
space using one way or another right i
was thinking congestive methods is more
like they're using monica methods
of the regularization probably something
else
so let me let me give you an example
okay two examples so the first example
is k-means so k-means can be viewed as
an energy-based model
where the the energy of a point in uh in
in white space okay there's no x in k
means because it's completely
unsupervised right so it's right
whatever but the energy of the y is the
the square distance to the closest
prototype okay
the energy surface is basically a bunch
of quadratic balls centered on the
prototypes and it's the minimum of all
those quadratic balls right
the volume of space that can take low
energy is limited by by k you only have
k
of those
energy wells and so the volume of low
energy space is determined by that k
okay
uh it's a it's a non-contrasting method
it's not regularized because k is fixed
but now let me take the example of a
regularized method sparse coding so
sparse cooling
you have a latent vector z
and you multiply it by a matrix okay a
decoding matrix the single layer
and your energy function is the squared
reconstruction error so the difference
between your y vector and
z multiplied by
the w matrix
and then there is an additional term
which is the l1 norm of z multiplied by
some coefficient right
so
this term is a regularizer that says i
make you pay
for setting too many components of the z
vector
uh to nonzero values right and the
result of this is to limit the volume of
white space that can take low energy and
you don't have to appeal to any
probabilistic arguments you don't have
to appeal to any positive thing
uh you just have a regularizer that
limits the volume of stuff that can take
low energy you know and
i'm looking for other algorithms like
this and the
basically i was looking for one that
would work for gentlemen architectures
yeah yeah i see your point i see your
point the difference here is that the
model are different right so
if you're learning a general energy
model where the energies of you know
complicated neural network you have to
kind of integrate and then you have to
do some approximation but now if you
have a simpler model and maybe a smart
way to you know manipulate models so
that you don't have to do the
integration
um but still achieve something similar i
agree
thank you professor liu uh yeah i saw i
saw i saw keema from uh from google
that
would be very a relevant person to ask
questions and he just laughed so i did
not catch him
yeah so uh
uh actually ima do you would you like to
say hi
hi yeah uh
how are you so i'm so sorry i missed the
first part of your talk i had another
meeting
uh catch the end of it but i'll follow
up on the discussion right um i think
i'm probably we'll go to verity of the
talk so you talk about this energy
function a measuring of contrastive or
contractive now one of the things we've
been working on is actually based on
this information theoretical measure
just
almost just measuring the volume of data
that's right um just similar to what you
mentioned it's not a rate reduction
redistortion and
taking care of really trace out the
volume of the data especially the
representation of the data that could be
one candidate for has you know many
interesting properties and like similar
to i actually think about it as a
general your example is perfect right
the sparse model and you can think about
this is a more generalization of that to
multiple low-dimensional subspaces
rather than just the more generic uh
sparse sparsities so yeah i should have
mentioned that uh yi actually has
proposed uh
probably one of the best alternative to
v craig perhaps a better one actually uh
called uh uh
uh rate reduction squared are you there
radio reduction just uh maximum rate
reduction it's essentially the volume of
the whole minus the parts yeah right so
his method also
is a criterion on the coherence matrix
of the activations of the code which
basically tries to
make the
log determinant of the covariance matrix
one and that has the effect of making
the covariance matrix uh identity so so
it's very similar to v crag you know
it's a different formulation but it's
you know basically is trying to do the
same thing
um and uh you know i think it's a great
alternative in fact one of my postdoc
ubh is actually using it so
now we will talk about i'll go to uh
fair to talk about it i think i gave a
similar talk uh at the
same event before yeah
we'll have more chat about it thanks
thank you we should respect people who
wrote questions on the chat box so i'll
let professor yano kun to decide which
question to ask to
answer uh yeah remind do you mind the
questions
or just a sample right any sample you
like to
okay i'm gonna start from the bottom
then um
okay
does the general jetpack system need
bi-level or multi-level optimization to
deal with latent variable z
does that pose a problem for
optimization so
that of course depends entirely on the
precise architecture that you put
um you know inside the the encoder on
the predictor well the encoder actually
doesn't matter but to make the to infer
the latent variable you basically you
can do gradient based methods so you can
back propagate gradient of the
reconstruction of the prediction cost
through the predictor down to the latent
variable and sort of optimize the latent
variable this way by a gradient-based
method
if your predictor is not
too complicated as a function of the
latent then you know it will be simple
on the other hand if your predictor is a
really complicated function of your
of your latent then uh it may not be
that simple
so i you know that depends on the detail
and i can't i can't really give you an
answer we've done some experiments with
kind of a
you know a don't embedding architecture
uh based on images with two two images
where the the predictor basically is
trying to
predict a transformation between the two
images
and it seems to work okay but it's
really preliminary and we don't have any
papers on this by the way i should
mention that there's going to be a blog
post about this that's going to be
published by meta-ai tomorrow
which kind of explains some of the ideas
that i talked about in this uh in this
talk
and uh i'm finishing a paper that kind
of talks about all of this which should
appear over the next uh
couple weeks or something like that so
you'll have a
written version of this if you want
okay what should we do next
up to you
uh or maybe shorter questions like in
the new architecture is there room for
including that shorter
accountability i don't know what that
means
i mean accountability here if if you
think about
if by accountability you mean um
uh you know can can i
align the behavior of my autonomous
agent to
um so that you know it doesn't kill
people and you know it does good things
etc
the place to do this would be inside of
the
intrinsic cost so basically the
intrinsic cost module
is a set of immutable
uh cost functions
okay they're not trained they're they're
hardwired
and they're there to essentially to do
that to drive the system towards certain
behaviors
and prevent it from
adopting certain behaviors as well right
so
inside of these clutch functions you can
you can do things that would be
difficult to program directly right it's
easy to program a robot to
uh like you know
not move its arm faster than a certain
speed right
but
but there are certain behaviors that are
easier to specify by a cost function
than by uh directly programming a
behavior so that's that's how you would
do it you would you would
program it in you know as a module
inside of the intrinsic cost essentially
thank you
um
yeah so so if you ask me to pick one
maybe so can you summarize that one so
do you think the research paradigm ai
will be more like a physics in the
future
may the success of physics research
inspired by ai community somehow yeah
by what i'm sure you missed the word
uh
may the success of fisk's research
inspire the ai community somehow and
that's the question
and that's the that's the one two three
four the
from the bottom the number four question
four from the bottom okay yeah
yeah
i see i see i see yeah um
i mean i'm a big fan of the connection
between physics and machine learning for
two reasons
first because i think
physics can bring
methods to machine learning that i think
are useful methodologies for you know
mathematical analysis of various kinds
so you see now uh a community of you
know reasonably uh large community of
physicists
mostly statistical physicists using
statistical physics methods to analyze
the
convergence for example or generalize
generalization properties of a deep
learning system and i think that's
really interesting
so that's that's one thing is to use of
physics methods to understand deep
learning okay
and certainly you know i talk about
energy-based models like all the math
that is in there essentially is derived
from uh thermodynamics essentially from
statistical physics
um
now there is the other way around like
can machine learning be
useful for physics and and there i think
it can in different ways so
uh
one
possible connection which is a little
kind of speculative at the moment
is the connection between uh
reversible models in machine learning
and
and quantum physics or quantum computing
in particular
um i don't want to say too much about
this because uh it's a bit you know
outside of
of of uh
you know some of the things i i i know
but but i think it's kind of interesting
and so promising uh area of contact but
i think by far the the sort of biggest
uh promising
kind of work is the application of
machine learning to uh
phenomenological models of physical
systems that are
basically systems with emergent
properties so um
there's a lot of
you know materials we're trying to
design for i don't know for batteries
for you know catalyst for chemical
reactions or or things like that right
or semiconductor metamaterials optical
electro-optical materials things like
that right so we can we could design
materials like atom by atom and the
problem with this is that we cannot
predict their properties very well
uh we can do you know
uh
uh
you know electron
density simulation and stuff like that
but um but we cannot really predict
their properties very well there's a lot
of materials for which you know they
have properties that were discovered a
little by accident and and and it took a
long time for people to really
understand what was going on
uh one example is this uh
magic angle superconductivity so you
take a
single atomic layer of graphene
okay so graphene is just you know a
bunch of hexagonal carbon uh lattice of
carbon atoms and you put another one on
top of it and you twist those two by
some magic angle it's one point
something degrees
and all of a sudden it becomes
superconductor right
it has to be at fairly low temperature
um but it only works for this magic
angle
like why right
and and so there's a lot of properties
like this that are really not explained
they're not predicted
and i think there's a lot of
opportunities in
training deep learning system to
basically predict properties of complex
physical systems that would allow us to
design you know better
materials better
drugs you know better
i don't know helicopter blades you know
whatever
that's very
very promising
uh thank you i saw two questions about
this technical question about z in zap
in that part so there are
yeah uh so can you explain the
introduction about z in japan for
example what is the meaning of z
in byol and uh
yeah so that's the third question to the
from the
bottom okay so byul does not have any
latent variable
okay there's no z in the oil
um
because the two representations in byol
uh have to be equal or one has to be i
mean you you you take one representation
run it through
a neural net that you train but it's
fixed it doesn't have latent variables
and then you you make the output of that
predictor and the other representation
equal so there's no latent variable in
uh
mbyol
in fact the experiment with v crack that
i presented there is no latent variable
either there's not even a predictor
actually
you just make the two representations
equal okay yeah the continuous question
is for black model z might be the
position of the masked program yeah so
that's a no uh invert model the z is
trivial in both models there is no
latent variable inside the model the
only place where there is a latent
variable invert
is which of the words are you going to
choose so when bird produces a
prediction for a word what it produces
is a a
a distribution a vector of distribution
right of a probabilities a distribution
over words
and then when you generate text you have
to
to sample from that distribution
when you pick one word from that
distribution you are instantiating a
latent variable
right it's basically you can think of it
as a switch that picks which of the
words you're going to output at that
time and the position of that switch is
a latent variable you pick a word you
set the switch that's your latent
variable now the problem with this kind
of latent variable invert is that it's
not an abstract latent variable it's an
it's a little variable that is in the
space of the outputs
and so it's completely useless
because what you want is an abstract
latent variable that
would allow you for example when you
when you change it to change the style
of the of the
of the text you're producing okay
for example it would say the same thing
but it changed you know you change the
style
but bird doesn't have that
you you don't have abstract hidden
variable invert
it's a generity model
thank you
so the z the more questions so does the
general java system needs by level or
multi-level optimization to deal with
the latent variable z does that pose a
problem for optimization
well so that i kind of partially
answered that already that
again it depends on your architecture so
if you have a simple predictor
finding the
finding the best z that minimizes the
prediction error is going to be
relatively simple you can also use
tricks like amortized inference right so
you can train a neural net that looks at
sx and xy and tries to predict the
optimal value of z from s x and x y
and then you can use this as an
initialization for your optimization
process of the latent variable
uh you have to be very careful when you
do this to limit the information content
of z otherwise you get attachment fees
but
but but that's kind of a legitimate way
to do this and that's the trick that
variational auto encoders use
variational auto encoders they cheat
they look at the output to guess the
value of the latent variable okay
which they make noisy to limit this
information content but um but they do
that they do advertise inference
thank you so continue doesn't seem to be
another question about geopower so i
might as well
so can japan that's the last one
do you mind reading it
the very last one
right can you play framework be applied
to
learn a unified embedding space for
general
uh proposed ai to process various tasks
and adapt to new tasks
how can we construct a unified space for
uh
general ai um to be designed by humans
or learn by multitask learning i think
it should be learned first of all by
multi-touch planning i don't know but
certainly learned whether there should
be a single general space i don't know
either i mean perhaps the
i mean there's one thing i kind of
didn't quite explain here but the the
way the the word model
would store its uh
idea of the state of the world
you could think of this as just you know
a multi-dimensional array you know a
neural net
okay
so your your world model is some
something on it and it predicts you know
a vector or tensor or something
but you could also imagine that
what the the word model does is that it
writes into the into the short-term
memory
uh and sort of updates its idea of the
state of the world so for example
um if i tell you
uh i tell you a story right and in this
story i tell you that
john is in the kitchen
and there is a a bottle of milk in the
kitchen and
and you know jane is in the
is in the
backyard
okay and uh now jane moves to the
kitchen okay now you know that there are
two people in the kitchen
because
and what you did is that you know
you you updated your your
sort of current
idea of the state of the world right
you can do this by basically updating
the content of some associative memory
so i think that's really the process
that should be used to keep a
track of the state of the world not just
store the entire state of the world in a
vector but basically
have the world model right to an
associative memory and update whatever
is you know required to uh to update
thank you thank you yeah now it's almost
8 40 so we stole several minutes from
you just one more okay
do you mind well it's up to you if you
want to ask answer one more question so
your answer
just one more i actually have to uh give
a talk tomorrow at 9 30 so
yeah
at some point
so who want to ask the last question so
i'm not going to take so whoever
and so actually there's the one in the
chat box the last question so
you mentioned contrast learning cannot
scale to logic dimensions how large is
large for example latent dimensions of
8758
bert is tiny
uh the latent dimension of bird is not
like the relevant dimension in bird is
not the latin uh is not the the code
inside of the
network
uh
it's uh what is the dimension of the
variable you're trying to predict right
and in invert it's very simple because
the the variable you're trying to
predict is discrete
so
you can represent a distribution over a
discrete set of outcomes
okay the output of of birth is a bunch
of
soft max vectors
that indicate distributions over words
right so i can do a softmax over all
words in the english dictionary and the
chinese
mandarin dictionary or whatever right
i cannot do a softmax over all possible
video frames
that is just impossible
okay because it's a high-dimensional
continuous space
i cannot discretize it in any useful way
i cannot represent it by any kind of
common distribution like a gaussian or
something like that
i just cannot represent the distribution
over uh
certainly not a normalized distribution
uh over the set of all possible video
frames
and so that's that's that's where that's
where contrastive running fails but of
course over discrete sets which is what
bert
handles it works
it's easy
we can do soft max with 100 000
different icons that's easy to do
very good so this this concludes
tonight's uh
and the seminar and all this fun events
and let's all thank the the speaker of
dr yanukov there's no good way to say
thank you and
but i will do it so
thank you very much and uh well thank
you so much ping for having me that was
uh that was fun uh thanks for organizing
uh thanks for everyone who
woke up early or
are going to bed late
thank you
okay you good night thank you all right
take care